today on the matt welsh show the left
insists that teachers absolutely aren't
sexually indoctrinating elementary
schoolers yet there's video footage of
teachers doing precisely that also pete
boudejig says that children will die if
he and his fellow groomers are not
allowed to say whatever they want to our
kids the truth is that gender ideology
is professed by buddhists and others is
what will kill kids and is killing kids
also donald trump endorses pro-abortion
anti-gun pro-trans dr oz and a jury
refuses to convict
the men entrapped by the fbi in a plot
to kidnap the governor of michigan plus
sam elliott issues the inevitable
groveling apology for committing the sin
of not liking a gay cowboy movie in our
daily cancellation some libertarians on
youtube try to debunk me we'll see how
they did all of that and more today on
the matt well show
[Music]
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you are
helping these left-leaning companies
donate to pro-choice causes and
candidates you probably don't like that
but that's the fact that matter a common
question i get from my listeners is what
can i do to help turn the tides in the
culture well here's a great first step
defund the abortionists don't let them
take your money and use it to further
policies that you don't believe in
switch to charity mobile today and they
will send five percent of your monthly
plan price to any pro-life charity of
your choice charity mobile offers the
latest 5g phones with no device or
service contracts plus great nationwide
coverage that sounds like a hassle i
assure you it isn't charity mobile makes
switching from your current carrier
painless their live customer service is
exceptional it will guide you through
the process you can keep your number and
even your phone in most cases or if you
want you can take advantage of my
special offer and get a free cell phone
with free activation all you have to do
is call this number 1-877-474
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walsh join the fight for the
lives of children by switching to
charity mobile today as we have noted
one of the interesting things about the
leftist reaction to the anti-groomer
efforts in florida and elsewhere is that
they tell us the laws are totally
unnecessary because nobody is trying to
sexually indoctrinate young children
anyway and they also tell us that the
laws are an assault on human rights and
will result in millions of gay people
dying of unspecified causes the laws
will do nothing and also they will do
very horrible things at the exact same
time these claims obviously can't both
be true but let's look at them
individually if this is a non-issue and
there is no sexual indoctrination of
children happening anyway then
it's very hard to explain
this video just posted by our nation's
leading journalist libs of tiktok here
we see a first grade teacher at a boston
charter school brook charter school is
what it's called instructing students in
grades k through two
about transgenderism during what is
being called an identity share zoom call
listen to this
all right so something that's really
cool and unique about who i am is that i
am transgender
so we touched a little bit about that at
the beginning of this week uh in the
book that miss hammond read but i'm
gonna give you my explanation about what
it means to be transgender as well
so when babies are born the doctor looks
at them and they make a guess about
whether the baby is a boy or a girl
based on what they look like and most of
the time that guess is 100 correct there
are no issues whatsoever
and but sometimes the doctor is wrong
the doctor makes an incorrect guess
when the doctor makes a correct yes
that's when a person is called cisgender
when a doctor's guess is wrong that's
when they are transgender so
i'm a man but when i was a baby the
doctors told my parents i was a girl
and so my parents gave me a name that
girls typically have and bought me
clothes that girls typically wear um and
until i was 18 years old everyone
thought i was a girl and this was super
super uncomfortable for me because i
knew that wasn't right um the way i like
to describe it is like wearing a super
itchy sweater the longer you wear it the
itchier it gets and the only way to make
the itching stop is to have everyone see
and know the person that you really are
so when i was 18 i told my family and my
friends that i'm really a boy and it was
like this huge weight had been lifted
off of my shoulders and i had the
freedom to be who i truly am and even
though this experience is super
challenging sometimes um i am it made me
the person i am and i'm super proud to
be transgender
this person is a disgrace to plaid first
of all i'm ashamed to be wearing plaid
on a day like today remember
um nobody is talking to little kids
about transgenderism even though we have
seen video after video after video of
exactly that teacher is doing exactly
that and openly admitting that they've
done and will continue to do exactly
that the teacher in the video tells the
little helpless children that there are
two categories of people
um transgenders and cisgenders now it's
worth i think it's worth lingering here
for just a moment to consider
uh that claim in a little bit more depth
that is after all something that you
know we can do as reasonably intelligent
adults we can analyze claims made by
other adults
and figure out whether they're credible
lots of grown-ups in this country aren't
even capable of that much so then what
chance do little kids have in that case
how are they supposed to sift through
the nonsense and decipher truth from
propaganda
again there are millions of adults in
this country who will hear
what the person in that video said and
think yep makes perfect sense
so if adults can hear all of that
blathering gibberish and be duped by it
what hope is there for like a
seven-year-old
yet those of us who have maintained our
capacity for critical thought might
notice that the transgender versus
cisgender thing is first of all
simply one binary system
being substituted for another
now these people insist that the gender
binary is artificial and limiting and
then they turn around and introduce a
different system that is also binary
and where did they get the cisgender
thing from
it's obvious why they find the term
useful it implies that normal people who
identify as the sex they were born are
not actually normal but are instead just
one possible variation
it also helps to reframe all human
beings in the terms and language of lgbt
ideology calling us cis genders
essentially like it's like the the lgbt
version of a vicarious baptism
we are all baptized into their worldview
whether we like it or not
but where did the cisgender word come
from
as it turns out the term was first
coined in 1991 by a german sexologist
named volkmar sagush
um in a paper titled transsexuals and
are no so
no some more
nosomorphic nosomorphic view
whatever that means
now you'll notice a theme here
almost every depraved and insane thing
in our culture today at least as it
relates to sex can be traced back to
20th century sexologists especially
german sexologists
and just like almost all the rest of
them sagash took a rather tolerant view
of pedophilia
drawing a distinguishing line between
pedophiles and what he called quote
pedosexuals
he said in an interview a few years ago
that
pedosexuals can be quote kind-hearted
informed and enlightened
and that we should not try to cure them
of their quote desires
but instead we should just try to you
know keep them
from making physical contact with
children so it's not the desire is not
the problem it's just the it's just the
the act itself
as mentioned this accepting approach to
pedosexuality is uh quote-unquote
pedosexuality as
as this person calls it
is a through line that connects
nearly all of the 20th century
sexologists and psychology quacks who
invented gender ideology john money and
alfred kinsey principle among them
so keep all this in mind
when you hear the claims that critical
race theory is just a legal theory and
it isn't taught in schools
well cisgender
was coined in a german sexology paper 30
years ago now now it's being taught to
kindergarteners
so there is a pipeline that takes
radical obscure left-wing ideas directly
into grade school and out into the wider
culture
the pipeline in this case is more of a
sewage line and we're all now living in
the filth and muck that dumps out on the
other end
there's something else worth um noting
in the video though
the groomer teacher says that
doctors guess
about whether a baby is a boy or a girl
and i've heard this variation more and
more frequently this idea of well it's
just a guess
and it is a kind of a significant
departure from the usual sex assigned at
birth narrative that we get from these
people
now that narrative is also completely
false of course but because doctors no
more assign a child sex than they assign
the child's species or dna structure
but at least the assigned language pays
some moderate deference to the concept
of biological sex
the sex is assigned quote unquote based
on the child's reproductive organs
but even that is too much
for the trans ideologues
by changing the language to guess
the groomers are convincing children
that the sex on their birth certificate
is a completely random totally arbitrary
haphazard designation it's all a roll of
the dice
it's not even an estimation or a theory
or a prediction or a construct
it's simply a guess
like you know i might guess about
whether you're holding a quarter in your
right or left hand
that kind of guess
the effect quite intended of course is
to make the child listening to this
begin to question whether the doctor
guessed correctly in his own case
it is destabilizing to the child
he thought he knew himself but now he's
not so sure
this is where the identity crisis begin
it begins it is caused it is imposed it
is started intentionally
and then years later after a childhood
full of unnecessary confusion self-doubt
self-loathing
if that child then tragically succumbs
to despair
and hurts or kills himself
the same people who sent him down that
path will then turn around and blame
those of us who had absolutely nothing
to do with it
this was illustrated late last week with
this exchange between pete buttigieg and
the clucking hens of the view listen
my state of florida when the with the
so-called don't say gay
law now um which
he says will kill kids do you agree
and you know as a politician because
this this strikes you as you know your
husband is a teacher
you are uh
obviously lgbtq yourself and you are now
a parent yeah
so how do you feel yeah he's right and
and i think every law to be judged for
the effect it's going to have on real
people in real life and i get the
political reasons why they're doing this
by the way some of those political
reasons
they don't have a plan on anything else
right i mean they they don't have a plan
on dealing with inflation or or dealing
with with gas prices or dealing with the
issues
yes he says the law will kill kids
if he's not allowed to groom children
they will die
let him and his grooming comrades
all of them the teachers like the woman
we saw in the first video
let them let them have their their way
let them unfettered access to our
children or else our kids will die
it is the most insidious and vile form
of emotional blackmail imaginable
and it's made all the more sinister by
the fact that buddhijage is the one who
is getting kids killed
him and the other gender ideologues
they're the ones doing it
they are getting kids killed
they are depriving children of identity
of truth
of true self-acceptance
and a great many of these kids will die
and are dying because of it
and it's their fault
the groomers it's their fault
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you ever wondered how big tech knows so
much about you three words free email
services when you click accept on those
terms and conditions you're giving that
free email provider the go ahead to scan
and analyze your email free email
services are data hoarders i switched to
start mail because i was done letting
big tech make billions by selling the
information in my email start mail keeps
my email private period it's simple as
that every email can be encrypted even
if the recipient doesn't use encryption
when you delete an email and start mail
it's gone forever never to be seen again
and start mail uses their own servers
which means they can't be put out of
business so switching to start mail is
also it's uh it's easy it's seamless you
can easily transfer all all of your
current email data so there's no
starting from scratch you have to worry
about that you get unlimited anonymous
aliases this feature protects your main
email address from spam and phishing
attacks so when you're giving your email
to a company but you want to protect
your identity start mail can generate a
shareable alias email so people can't
sell your information and they can be
deleted anytime you want your cyber
security has never been more at risk or
more important so keep your private
information private with start mail sign
up today and you'll get 50 off your
first year go to
startmail.comwalsh.startmail
with a t s t a r t mail.com
walsh for 50 off your first year start
mail.com walsh
all right um
let's see
first of all i have to address something
the most important thing of the data to
to mention um a controversy that's been
brewing
yesterday i went uh out with my family
to a lake nearby the lake was like 40
degrees but the kids they still went
swimming because kids are weirdly
impervious to pain actually they're kind
of both i was thinking about this
yesterday
kids are weirdly impervious to pain but
also overly sensitive to it at the same
time so my kids will swim in a in a
freezing lake or they'll like fall 40
feet out of a tree and then pop up like
nothing happen but then five seconds
later you know they'll get a paper cut
and scream like somebody shot an arrow
through their hand um anyway so we were
there and i'm lounging i'm vibing as the
kids would say and my wife snapped a
photo again as always to shame me
and this photo has elicited mockery on
instagram but you know i have no shame
so here it is you can see
uh i have the yeah i have the
birkenstock sand uh sandals with socks
that i'm wearing out in public
the chinos the ball cap
that you may not like this is what i
gotta tell you may not like it
you may not agree with it
but this is peak male fashion right here
you know what this is it's white dad
summer 2.0 it's already begun and it's
going to get wild this year it's going
to get absolutely wild white dad summer
it means not only that are you're
dressed to the nines all the time like i
am but you're partying all night every
night
and by that i mean
from when the kids go to bed until 9 15
when you fall asleep on the couch
and by partying i mean nothing that
resembles partying at all
that's what white does summer is all
about um all right one other thing i
also have to note not related but also
important is uh if you have not signed
up for the uh for my newsletter where
you can hear all kinds of interesting
insights about my fashion and other you
know important
news related items as well you can go to
mattwallsreport.com i believe is the url
right yeah mattwatchreport.com and sign
up for my newsletter comes out uh once a
week every friday
and uh if you're not signed up for it
yeah mattwallreport.com get signed up
okay
let's start here it's from breitbart it
says
former president donald trump endorsed
celebrity doctor
dr oz in pennsylvania's u.s senate race
on saturday after his initial pick sean
parnell dropped out amid a contentious
custody battle with his with his
estranged wife last fall trump said his
endorsement of oz is all about winning
elections in order to stop the radical
left maniacs from destroying our country
trump said in a statement the great
commonwealth of pennsylvania has a
tremendous opportunity to save america
by electing the brilliant and well-known
dr mehmet oz for the united states
senate i have known dr oz for many years
as as have many others even if only
through his various uh through his very
successful television show trump touted
the thousands of life-saving heart
operations oz has performed throughout
his medical career
um and the eight new york times
bestsellers he authored
trump also pointed to oz's pro-life
views right and his strength on the
border election fraud in the military
has reasons for his endorsement trump
said dr oz is pro-life very strong on
crime the border election fraud our
great military and our vets tax cuts
that will always fight for and support
our under siege second amendment he will
ensure america will become energy
independent again dr oz also
passionately believes in high quality
education and protecting parent
involvement throughout the process
okay
none of that just so you know none of
that is remotely true at all dr oz
is and has always been pro-abortion
anti-gun
he's spoken about this publicly many
times now maybe when he started running
for for senate
he experienced the conversion on all of
these issues all at once but that's
going to make you a little bit skeptical
i mean somebody i don't know how old dr
oz is he's his let's say his mid-60s at
least
so guy in his mid-60s has a certain
point of view for his entire life
and then decides to run for office as a
republican and all at once magically
look at that he's a he has it's a it's a
road to damascus moment
what a coincidence
no dr oz is without a doubt a full-on
leftist not just
not just uh like lien's liberal
establishment republican type he is a
leftist and i'll play a video in a
second that proves this he is a far left
leftist
he is actually about as far left as you
can be he's on the cutting edge of
leftism right now or or damn near it at
least
and uh
i mean we don't even
there are so many problems with dr oz we
don't even need to mention the fact that
he's not at all qualified to be senator
the fact that he was a tv doctor for 20
years i don't see i don't really see the
correlation between that and being an
effective senator then again senators
don't really do much anyway so i guess
anyone could be qualified for it so
that's not even that's not my problem
with him
my problem is that he is a far
left leftist
that's my issue
that donald trump decided to endorse now
um
i've heard over the weekend many excuses
for donald trump because there are
people
on the right lots of people on the right
who are always ready and eager to make
excuses for donald trump because we've
decided
um and this has been the case for ever
since trump was on the scene as a
political figure
it's been decided generally speaking by
the right that trump is never
responsible for anything that he does
it's all like any any mistake is always
somebody else's fault
and so the excuse that i'm hearing from
trump is that oh it's his advisors ah
those those damned advisors again
well maybe we should start asking first
of all if it is his advisor's fault why
is he so terrible at hiring advisors and
second of all is he not capable of
analyzing these things for himself and
seeing that dr oz i mean it took me five
minutes
to discover that dr oz is a leftist
and i haven't known him for my entire
life or i haven't known him for years
like trump has
so i don't buy that excuse i also don't
buy the excuse that um
that well the other guy you know the
other people there there are no good
candidates in the race right now for
senate on the republican side in
pennsylvania and they're all a bunch of
establishment milquetoast types and so
uh you know there's there is no good
option that i can believe
i certainly believe that so
but if that's the case then either you
endorse
nobody or if you are going to endorse dr
oz for some reason which i don't know
why you would because there's no way
he's the best
i don't care who the other guys are
there's no way that dr oz is better than
them
because it can't get much worse
but if you are gonna do it then just say
that he's the lesser of two evils that
he like he's not great but then again
uh you know he's more likely to win in
the general whatever your argument is
just be honest about it don't try to put
him forward as a pro-life champion
so if you want to know what dr oz is all
about
uh let's go back to one of his and this
is the great thing about a guy who's
been on tv forever is that he's
you could just go and watch the tape
he's he has addressed all of these
issues extensively
in interviews and on his own show and
he's made his views very clear
so this is from i believe several years
ago in fact
so dr oz
before it was
as popular as it is now on the left
to promote trans kids
before that
doctor that's why i said he's on the
cutting edge of leftism
here he was a few years ago on a show
um singing the praises of
childhood transgenderism watch
what if your son told you he was meant
to be a she she always knew that she is
a girl would you let your child become
the opposite sex talk to me about why i
decide to have a double mastectomy at
age 14. inside the lives of transgender
kids
this show is going to be controversial
for a lot of people challenging your
beliefs about what it means to be male
or female the word you'll hear today is
transgender
transgender it describes people who sex
on the outside doesn't match who they
are on the inside
now imagine your child is transgender
what would you do
our lives as parents are first defined
by the words it's a girl or it's a boy
could you make a decision to let your
child live as the other sex even alter
their body
it's an area of intense debate today
you'll meet families coping with this
astonishing reality
what does it mean to be a boy
what does it mean to be a girl
those two simple questions are
infinitely complex and gut-wrenching for
parents of children who are born
transgender
[Music]
eight-year-old josie was born joseph
physically she's a boy but from the time
she could talk josie knew she was a girl
it doesn't get any better by the way you
can see the entire episode you can
stomach it which is on youtube right now
um and and uh lest you try to make any
excuses for dr oz and say well he's just
talking about the issue
he's taken an objective
view of it well even that would be
terrible because you can't take an
objective view of children being
sexually abused which is what this is
there's there's no there's no well you
know these kids are being sexually
abused but let's let's think of it
objectively um that is already terrible
but that's not even what he's doing i
mean it's very clear in the episode that
he is promoting this he is he is
legitimizing and validating it using
his
doctor label to validate this stuff
um
and that's very it's very effective in a
lot of people's minds i mean there are a
lot of people who for years have been
sitting around watching these these um
these kinds of people on on tv
and they see this stuff promoted and
they think well hey
if dr oz says it's fine or that it's
valid then it must
be he says that uh well what does it
mean to be a boy
uh it's it's infinitely complex it's not
complex actually it's not complex at all
it's very simple
and you know you must know that as a
medical professional
so you watch that you think like this
guy
is running for senate as a republican
and he just got an endorsement from the
previous republican president
i it's the republican party is in
shambles
in shambles right now
but when when that i mean
if that becomes accepted
if that becomes fully mainstream
accepted on the right or among
republicans then it is over and i mean
it it's it's done it's over
um because that is
that has to be a deal breaker i don't we
could get into his positions on abortion
gun rights i mean all of it is bad but
if you're endorsing trans children
the concept of there being such a thing
as a trans child
um that has to be
the where the line is drawn deal breaker
that's it
and if it's not and if we let that
become the standard in the republican
party
then it's it's done it's over
then you have democrats and then other
side you have democrats and that's all
that there is
and i know you might say that we're
already in that position where you've
got the democrat party than the
democrat-like party
i would say that we're we're not there
yet
there is a battle within the republican
party right now over you know it's a
kind of a civil war it really depends on
on who wins that battle
because ron desantis
is also a republican and he obviously is
not endorsing transgenderism in children
so you've got two sides the two sides of
the public party kind of battling it out
right now
and if the side that wants to
mainstream this kind of stuff gender
ideology if they win
then it's done
politically it's done
all right let's go to this from the
federalists it says a jury refused on
friday to convict any of the four men
standing trial for supposedly plotting
to kidnap michigan michigan governor
gretchen whitmer after strong evidence
that the fbi tricked them into the plan
after 20 days of trial jurors determined
that daniel harris and brandon caserta
were not guilty of felony charges of
conspiracy to unlawfully seize confined
kidnap abduct and carry away and hold
for ransom and reward or otherwise the
governor of the state of michigan
jurors could not agree on the fates of
adam fox and barry croft jr the other
two so those men left the trial with no
verdict and with the possibility of
being brought to trial again prosecutors
representing the u.s department of
justice argue that the group of men were
anti-government extremists who scheme to
violently take down whitmer for her role
in promoting covenant 19 tyranny and
michigan
and but right now because the defense
argues
i think correctly
that
they this this was not their plot okay
before men they didn't come up with this
this wasn't their plot the fbi came up
with it and recruited them into it the
fbi came up with a plot to kidnap the
governor of michigan and then went and
suggested it to other people and tried
to recruit them into it and so who do
you blame for that you blame the fbi
and and that's why this
verdict or you know in two cases kind of
a non-verdict as it stands right now
um this is the right
decision we'll see what happens if
there's a if there's a retrial or
something hopefully there isn't
but my point is if you're if you're
really worried about
the police state
or you know
law enforcement abuses or whatever it is
you should be happy with this result
tentatively
you should be happy with it
because this is without a doubt
law enforcement abuse and there's a
whole lot of it that happens with the
fbi
uh but you don't find that on the left i
mean the left is very upset
that
they want all these guys to go to jail
forever
i think this is something that our side
gets wrong and that i get wrong
um or at least we we talk about this in
a way that's imprecise
because we often say and and i have said
that the left is anti-police
well
i mean they aren't actually
i kind of wish they were now i mean it's
not good to be anti-cop you shouldn't be
but at least that would be better than
what they actually are because at least
if you're just anti-cop in general
you're only you're basically an
anarchist then um that's a consistent
principle at least and it would mean
that you would be skeptical you'd be
consistently constantly skeptical
probably overly skeptical of law
enforcement
um
and but but it would mean that when
there's actual law enforcement abuse
happening on any side to anybody you
would be there and you'd be very
critical of it
if you're just anti-cop across the board
again not not the right approach but
it's better than what we actually get
from the left which is that um
their their view of law enforcement and
of police it really depends
on who's on the other side
like who who's who's the person being
arrested who's the person
uh potentially being abused
exploited whatever
well i mean when you when you look at
the way they react to
you know george floyd or michael brown
or any of these cases
with any of the blm martyrs
you'd be excused if if that's all you
saw of the left and of their approach to
law enforcement
you'd be excused for thinking that oh
these people just hate the cops because
like even when the police
are trying to arrest a violent criminal
in the case of michael brown the violent
criminals trying to kill them
and even then you know leftists are
are are not tolerant of the police using
any kind of lethal force in response
it seems like from their position from
their perspective if a violent criminal
is trying to kill a police officer it's
the police officer's ethical duty to
just stand there and allow themselves to
be killed
so you see that it seems like extreme
like an extreme anti-police bias
but then you go over to the other side
and you see
a capital police officer shooting an
unarmed woman in the neck inside the
capitol building and they're celebrating
that
you see the fbi blatantly trying to
entrap people into criminal conspiracies
and they're fine with that
so this is not a consistent principle
and that's because on the left there are
no consistent principles
period
this is a this is a relativistic view of
the world and so everything is always
relative
and that explains um
as daily wire reports leftist msnbc host
joy reid tweeted her discussed friday
with the michigan jury that did not
convict four men of conspiring to kidnap
michigan governor gretchen whitmer uh
reed as she often does focused on the
race and political leanings of the
accused men arguing that they were not
convicted because they're white
right-wing extremists
she tweeted quote unreal so in america
in the year of our lord 2022 you can
plot to kidnap a democratic woman
governor to stage a show trial hurt her
or worse because you don't like covet
restrictions and then you can walk as
long as you're a white right-wing
extremist
holy jury nullification batman
uh yes because when you look at the
response to january 6th from the federal
government
obviously the only conclusion you can
draw is that if you're on the right
law enforcement will just leave you
alone
right that's that's the obvious
conclusion
by the way joy reid since we're on the
subject she found other things to
racialize as well that should actually
be the name of her show i don't know i
don't know what the name of her show
actually is but uh whatever it is it
should be
racialized with joy reid i think that's
a much better name and here she is this
weekend looking at the racial element of
the media's focus on ukraine listen
we haven't witnessed the same type of
solidarity for the yemenis
as we do for the ukrainians we don't see
historic sanctions or global campaigns
corporations like airbnb and netflix
taking a stand and this is not to say
that we shouldn't care this much for
ukraine far from it
the point is we should also care this
much for refugees and those facing
occupation and war in the middle east
and asia and africa too
the coverage of ukraine has revealed a
pretty radical disparity in how human
ukrainians look and feel to western
media compared to their browner and
blacker counterparts with some reporters
using very telling comparisons in their
analyses of the war
it's very emotional for me because i see
european people with blue eyes and
blonde hair being healed children will
kill every day with putin's missiles the
unthinkable has happened to them and
this is not a developing third world
nation this is your this isn't a place
with all due respect um
you know like iraq or afghanistan that
has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully too uh city where
you wouldn't expect that or hope that
it's going to happen
civilized okay let's face it the world
is paying attention because this is
happening in europe if this was
happening anywhere else would we see the
same outpouring of support and
compassion
but we don't need to ask ourselves if
the international response would be the
same if russia unleashed their horror on
a country that wasn't white and largely
christian because russia has already
done it in syria
this is a teachable moment for us in the
media
we aren't afraid to call out our own
industry there is a lot of
soul-searching that we need to do in
western media about why some wars and
lives seem to matter more than others
uh first of all
not to get into semantics but actually
the media the media did focus uh
syria dominated the headlines for for
months
um
but all of her criticisms about the
media you know and their focus on
ukraine like that you're you work for
msnbc that's you you're one of the
drivers of this
and i actually agree as i've as i argued
from the beginning
that
the focus on ukraine is out of
proportion with
the way we look at other parts of the
world
it's not it's not for racial reasons
though
and by the way
if you want to make it racial
well you could easily look at it from
the other end
why is the media focused on ukraine so
much
well yeah you could say that the the
victims in this case
have have it you know appear to be white
have lighter have a lighter skin tone
and so that's why people are focused on
um okay well the the bad guys
right people people on the other side
putin
you could just as easily argue from the
perspective of left-wing media
you know they prefer this story because
they like him as a bad guy
whereas if you go into other parts of
the world you're going to find that yes
the victims are not white but also the
bad guys aren't white
so you'd easily look at it that way
if you want to racialize it
becomes a double-edged sword
but really the racial narrative
either way is it it doesn't really
explain it
and the fact is that afghanistan
did dominate the headlines for a few
months
back around the time of the after of the
afghanistan uh pull out
it really is up to
why
like why do we focus on this so that we
focus on afghanistan as afghanistan
afghanistan afghanistan and then we just
drop it like a hot potato move on to the
next thing
i mean it's not like everything it's not
like everything is fixed in afghanistan
it's not like it's better
we just moved on or talking about
something else
why is that
well i g we should
we should ask the media we should ask
joy reid go talk to your bosses about
that
they're the ones who are determining
this
um it's not it's not a right-wing
conspiracy
it's a corporate media decision
and the corporate media is not run by
white
uh right wingers i can tell you that
all right one other thing i got to play
for you this is uh
we could call it disappointing also not
really disappointing because it's
totally expected sam elliots is of
course the famous iconic hollywood actor
and
a couple a few weeks ago we um gave him
some credit because he
was asked about this power of the dog
which is this artsy western terrible
boring movie doll very dull movie that's
i mean i i defy you to watch that movie
and make it through 15 minutes without
falling asleep and it was nominated for
a bunch of awards and everything and
it's about a gay cowboy and the critics
are hailing it because of the gay themes
and everything else um
sam elliott in a podcast was asked about
this movie he gave an honest answer he
said he doesn't he doesn't like it he
doesn't you know he just doesn't he
doesn't need those kinds of themes in a
western he likes the more traditional
westerns that's his that was his honest
opinion about it
and um
of course people were very upset about
his honest opinions because he was asked
about his opinion of the movie
but just because as we've learned just
because you're asked about your opinion
of something that doesn't mean that
you're that you're actually entitled to
give your opinion
what they want to hear is you repeat the
accepted opinion
and pretend like it's your own whether
it is or not
and so people are very upset about that
and uh
and same elliot was on a panel a couple
days ago was asked again and he is now
singing a little bit of a different tune
listen
yeah first don't go to a podcast whose
call letters are wtf
[Laughter]
that movie
stuck struck a chord with me
and then
trying to
[Music]
tell the guy
the wtf guy how i felt about the film
i wasn't very articulate about it
i didn't articulate it very well
and i said some things that hurt people
and i feel terrible about that
the gay community has been
incredible to me
my entire career
[Applause]
and i mean my entire career from before
i got started when i was in this town
friends on every level
in every job description
up until today with my agent my dear
friend my agent of a number of years
i'm sorry that i hurt any of those
friends
and someone that i loved
and anyone else
by
the words that i used
is he gonna cry it looks like he's about
to cry
i couldn't keep listening to the
watching the clips i don't know where
where it goes
it can't go anywhere good from here
it just goes to show look these these
are actors the characters they portray
on screen are fake of course and
oftentimes do not reflect who they
really are at all so sam elliott has
made a career playing these kind of
gritty
tough uh you know western badass type
figures
and here he is on a panel in hollywood
crying because people were had their
feelings hurt by his opinion about a
movie he's he's apologizing to the
people who he hurts
and those are people who were hurt by
sam elliott's opinion of power of the
dog
they they were hurt because sam elliott
had an opinion about a movie
that they disagreed with
hurt
we never get any specifics on how this
like in what way were they hurt how
could they have been hurt by that but
they were so sam elliott grovels and
apologizes
uh it's just it's a damn shame
i mean he's old he's in his you know
he's in his 70s he's obviously rich he's
got plenty of money
um
and he has everything that he needs
to just throw up the middle finger
to all of the sensitive cry bullies
that not even really sensitive the
pretend sensitive cry bullies and say
you know what i don't care
but he's not going to do that because he
lives in hollywood and and this is how
he's been
he himself has been conditioned his
whole life
and it won't matter either
he is it doesn't you've already it's too
late sam you've revealed your actual
opinion about something
the cat's out of the bag
and everyone knows the secret now they
know the secret that you actually have
your own opinions about things
and god forbid you you you maybe
sometimes enjoy watching movies
where um
there's there's not uh lgbt ideology
being being uh shoved in your face every
second like you'd sometimes prefer to
watch movies without that god forbid so
you've already revealed that they know
it now
and you can cry and apologize all you
want is not going to change it
could have kept your dignity
decided to give it up and you get
nothing in return
same old story
if you haven't heard of ben's book club
now's your chance to get signed up uh
last month he took members through his
analysis of a tale of two cities by
charles dickens and you can watch it now
at dailywire.com
watch remember third thursday book club
is a live experience where you get to
engage with ben shapiro in real time ask
questions and comment on the book today
we're premiering a new trailer check it
out here
i want to tell you about my third
thursday book club this is not your
average book club these are the greatest
books in the history of western
literature
we're going to dive into the greatest
works of all time these are the books
that helped form the key pillars of
western civilization and helped define
america and we're going to do it live
with thousands of you our daily wire
members
i'm gonna be your personal guide i've
read every one of these books i'm gonna
draw out the important lessons and
themes from every book plus i'm gonna be
answering your questions along the way
so we actually do read the book
together you join the book club you are
going to get smarter you're going to get
more knowledgeable because this is an
investment in your most valuable asset
your mind the third thursday book club
it's going to change the way you
[Music]
think you know when you sign up you'll
also get his notes which is a cheat
sheet to get the important lessons
themes and characters this month's book
is the once in future king by t.h white
you can sign up now at third
thursdaybookclub.com to get ben's notes
sent straight to your inbox for the once
and future king by t.h white
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
all right some comments saw from
friday's show john williams says i
cannot believe that anyone could listen
to what matt is describing and still be
pro-choice well they don't listen john
that's the trick um
they don't not just to me they just
don't listen
they tune it out
as much as they can
and that's how they remain pro-abortion
it's the only way that you can remain
pro-abortion i think
um is to be very careful about
what you expose yourself to i think it
was c.s lewis that said something along
the lines of it you know an atheist can
never be too careful in his reading
because
the point c.s lewis was making is that
atheism is this
um kind of this fragile
thing and you have to protect it very
carefully by making sure you don't
expose yourself to anything that could
that could shatter that view into a
million pieces um
and it's the same thing with being
pro-abortion that's that's why clinics
know this the abortion the the abortion
mills they know this for sure
that's why they've conspired with the
government they've got all these special
laws
no other by the way no other industries
no other private establishments get this
kind of law but they have their laws on
the books where you're not allowed to
get within x number of uh yards of an
abortion mill
even if you're not on their property
like public property they still get this
radius
no one else gets it they get it because
of this this uh relationship between the
abortion industry and government this
kind of incestuous relationship
so they have that they they've got
clinic escorts who come out and when the
women are coming in to kill their babies
they send the escorts out and the
escort's whole job is just to make sure
that the women don't look over at any
protesters who might be there they they
don't receive any of the literature that
someone might try to hand to them
it's all about keeping
you know this fragile thing intact
um
let's see nate says
if you make abortion illegal there will
be an influx of back alley procedures
well maybe the mother of the child would
reconsider something so dangerous if
they themselves could be put in harm's
way
uh yeah that's the correct response to
this back alley claim
that oh if we don't have abortions then
then you're gonna have unsafe and dirty
abortions that happen in back alleys
well the problem is that every abortion
is unsafe
by definition
the
the objective of the abortion is to
destroy
life and so there's no safe way to do it
and also it is a dirty evil terrible
thing to do in the first place
and in a civilized society you don't
provide
a nice clean welcoming environment
for people to do dirty evil destructive
horrible things
to their kids
most of all
um
let's see
mike mart says this biromantic
asexuality nonsense reminds me of the
infinite fracturing of musical styles
that the punk rock scenes spawned back
in the 90s you could no longer talk
about your favorite artist without the
initiated lecturing you on whether their
style was pre this post that neo
something or proto something else the
growing palette of genders and
sexualities creates an ever-increasing
array of self-branding opportunities for
people desperate to stand out in a
rather bland culture i want to say we
are reaching peak narcissism but we
could have a long way to go
yet before the worship of the self comes
into its full flower
very well put nothing i need to add
anything to it um james says matt after
your take on chain restaurants i have to
say you're banned from the show yes this
is another reason why i've been i'm
being viciously attacked today aside
from my my great style and my um my
sandals and socks
all i said
on twitter yesterday is that actually
all sit-down chain restaurants are fine
and some are even good
and in the vast majority of cases the
boutique kind of nice trendy restaurants
aren't enough of an improvement over the
chains to justify the price
that's my point so
for example
i've never been to a to a nice italian
restaurant that's enough of an upgrade
over olive garden or carabas to make it
worth the premium you pay for it i know
this is being treated like heresy and
i've got all the italians coming after
me how could you say this well it's it's
true i'm not yeah you could go to the
nice italian place and the spaghetti is
going to be you know a little better
than olive garden it's not better enough
to justify how much more you're paying
for it
that's my take and i'm sticking to it
and i look i've been to nice restaurants
all over the country i've been to the
kind of places that are renowned you
know you hear about oh this is famous
across the world it's the best place and
you go in
and um they're always
good but they're almost never good
enough for the price
and i usually leave there thinking man i
could have just gone to red robin
and paid a tenth of the price and i'd be
just as full right now and the food
experience would have been
only slightly worse
that's my take so that's a hot take
that's actually it's on the positive end
of things i don't do those very often
usually my hot takes are oh actually
this thing that you think is good is bad
i'm saying this thing that you think is
bad is actually good
so you should just everyone should
appreciate that for what it is at least
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we'll
be responding to another youtube video
which endeavors to expose humiliate and
debunk yours truly this one was posted
by two people named brad palumbo and
hannah cox they don't have a very large
following you'll see why in a moment and
perhaps by most standards are not worth
my time but they represent something
that i find particularly annoying and so
i can't really help myself they are smug
self-satisfied libertarians not that
there's any other kind of libertarian of
course and nothing irritates me more
than smug self-satisfied libertarians
which is why i feel compelled
to speak out and respond brad and hannah
react to three of my quote unquote
controversial opinions the first is my
take on the dating scene the second is
my opinion about alleged mental
illnesses like anxiety and depression
and the third is a tweet that i posted
like four or five years ago where i said
that yoga is a satanic pagan ritual
i stand by all of those opinions
especially the last one about yoga yoga
is most certainly a depraved despicable
and blasphemous and also sacrilegious
act
but as important as that discussion is
due to time constraints i'm going to
focus today on the portion of the video
which covers the first two subjects
there's a little bit more meat on the
bones there so let's get into it
hey guys i'm brad palumbo this is hannah
cox uh welcome back to libertarians
react we're the co-founders of base
politics and today we're reacting to the
one and only matt walsh
it's gonna be
really hot takish i think we're gonna
have very strong reactions so much what
he has to say if you don't know matt
walsh he's a blogger christian
conservative extreme traditionalist who
really likes to push his way of thinking
on other people that's something we
don't really stand for as libertarians
so we're gonna work through some of his
clips and break them down let us know
your thoughts make sure to leave your
comments as well
okay a couple of problems here first of
all turn the music in the background
down a few notches
uh also i'm not i haven't been a blogger
for like five years
um i'm a podcaster now get it right
podcast is is blogging in in vocal form
but still
uh also
these two characters are the co-founders
of something called based politics which
is like me being the founder of
something called
vegan feminist yoga politics actually
that would be far less absurd because i
am after all a best-selling women's
studies author but libertarians on the
other hand are definitely not based
especially not these libertarians in
fact it's it's fair to say that the term
based
could literally be defined as the
opposite of these two
speaking of not being based they accuse
me of pushing my way of thinking on
other people
what
how by expressing my opinions isn't that
exactly what
they are doing if i push my opinions on
other people by saying them out loud
then aren't they pushing their opinion
of me onto me by making an entire video
about me
when exactly does spoken opinion
graduate from being just an opinion to
being a form of compulsion
i'm assuming that line is crossed the
moment you say something that these two
don't like
let's continue
so in this first clip he uh endorses
arranged
marriages let's take a listen
now on the complete opposite end of this
spectrum are arranged marriages instead
of a boundless never-ending buffet of
options a young person in a culture that
practices arranged marriages will be
assigned just one and they don't even
make the choice
their families just pair them up and say
here you go
there's far less freedom and far less
autonomy in a system of that sort but it
is without a doubt oh superior to our
system
we would be happier
every person on the dating scene right
now would be happier if they were just
matched up with someone against their
will
against your will
that's a new dating app pray
against your will
here you go you're assigned this person
go make babies what the heck is right i
don't know how is it conservative to be
like yeah it would have a lot less
freedom and individual rights but it'd
be better that's like that's not what
conservatism in america has ever been
about how bad is your marriage is what i
want to know that you think people
should be like assign people like a
lottery system like here you go and that
would be just as good as whatever you
found i
it's a little rapey to be honest the
vibes of like yeah women should be
assigned to me as my wife
no they should not sir
they should not this seems like it comes
from a very insult kind of mindset of
like i can't get women on my own they
never pick me and she's just behind me
i know but he speaks for that product
yeah i guess
yeah
just a quick tip for any future
libertarians react videos i would dial
down the music but also the shrillness
and smugness by about eight or nine
points because right now you're at a
full 10 on the smarmy dork scale and
it's it's frankly a bit overwhelming
as mentioned libertarians in general
have a serious problem with smugness but
here i think we've met like the
libertarian smug
super spreaders these are patient zeros
of libertarian smugness they also have
zero in the way of arguments rebuttals
or clever comebacks uh they are of
course being wildly dishonest about my
argument i never said that arranged
marriages are ideal i also never said
that uh women should be assigned to me
to be married i also never mentioned
that women should be the only ones
subjected to it um i said that arranged
marriages are better than our current
approach today and that's simply because
our current approach couldn't possibly
be any worse
but is there at least some wisdom to the
arranged marriage model yes there is and
before you continue scoffing and gasping
at the very idea that there could be
anything redeeming in it consider that
many cultures around the world
especially non-western cultures have had
and still have such a system
are they all just a bunch of idiot
troglodytes brad and hannah
are you sure you want to make that
argument
if that's the broad brush you want to
use to paint billions of people and
dozens of culture cultures across the
world and throughout history
go for it i guess fits with the whole
smug theme i guess as for me my
preferred system is essentially the one
we had in this country before the modern
dating scene began to form and certainly
before hookup culture and dating apps
took hold i favor courtship where the
dating phase is understood by all
parties concerned to be the path to
marriage
typically in a courtship culture
families
may not choose your spouse but they are
heavily involved in selecting potential
matches this is far superior to our
current arrangement where a legion of
confused lethargic hapless
single people scroll endlessly through
avatars on their phones randomly
selecting one after another for fleeting
temporary flings or emotion infatuation
and physical attraction are the only
driving forces the only litmus test
you would in fact be better off just
having your family choose your spouse
for you
than
making decisions that way
which is the most superficial unreliable
and chaotic way possible and ironically
the girl in the video actually makes
this point for me
accidentally listen
no no one time my dad tried to set me up
with somebody and i was aghast at who he
thought i would like i was actually
insulted i was like dad you know i'm
cute right like
you know like i don't have a problem
pulling men right like
no
that was a suggestion it wasn't a it was
just what he would like me to be with
which was like the super christian guy
who was in his church and who like was
slightly balding but like he thought was
a good option for me he was like a
really good guy and i was like yeah i'm
gonna need a really good guy who's not
balding like and also who doesn't live
in anderson south carolina because i'm
for sure as hell not and like you know
those kinds of things so all i'm saying
is i would never i love my parents
dearly but i would never want them to
pick my mate they would they would have
no clue how to begin to pick who i would
actually want yeah no it's just creepy
uh and it's really crazy and i just
can't relate to that one at all
can someone make a video attacking me
that's that like put some effort into it
i'm looking for a good challenge here
this is just
so your your dad set you up with someone
who you admit is a really good guy but
he's losing his hair so you had no
interest in him and you say that you're
too attractive to be wasting your time
with men who have the audacity to
possess physical flaws now look i
wouldn't usually say what i'm about to
say but
speaking to the to the girl now you
earlier felt comfortable commenting on
my marriage inaccurately of course so
you've opened yourself up to some harsh
truths and here it is cupcake
you may be slightly overestimating
yourself you you seem to have
erroneously given yourself a couple of
extra points on the one to ten physical
attractiveness scale
just just just a tip
and even if you hadn't if you're single
and making your decisions based on
hairlines you're either going to be
lonely and miserable as you are right
now for the rest of your life or
eventually you're going to be
frivolously marrying some scumbag who
isn't a good guy but at least still has
all his hair and a short time later
you're gonna file for divorce and try to
make yourself into the victim of your
failed marriage when it's your own
vanity and stupidity that put you in
that position
one of those two results are your
destiny unless
you learn to look a little deeper in
your search for a mate the fact that you
can't look deeper right now and that
your father seems to have a better view
of who would be a good match for you
than you do only proves my point
you yourself specifically would be
better off with an arranged
marriage now i'm not sure i could say
the same for the poor sap who ends up
with you on the altar but you would
actually be better off with that
so from from here the dynamic duo moved
to my unorthodox opinions on alleged
mental illnesses like anxiety and
depression they didn't offer anything
that could reasonably just be described
as an argument against my take on dating
let's see if they might get around to
attempting an actual refutation on this
topic at least let's listen
one of the worst things to happen in
modern times is the medicalization of
the human condition now people who
experience anxiety think they're sick
they aren't anxiety is a fundamental
fact of human existence it is not a
disease
that's what i wrote that's what i
believe we have set out to medicalize
and diseasify every aspect of the human
condition every difficult emotion every
unpleasant personality trait
that's why the dsm now has something
like 300 mental disorders listed and
over 50 million adults in this country
have been diagnosed with at least one of
them
which one of those applies to trolls who
say outlandish things for attention
right
i hate this
yeah you hate this i do i'm very
bothered by it but it's also just like
very objectively wrong literally
depression is a chemical imbalance in
the brain
that you can observe in someone you can
look at the brain scan of somebody who's
clinically depressed for someone else
and see the difference it is not the
same as just feeling sad sometimes and
it's so harmful when so many people lose
their lives to these conditions and and
die by suicide
drug addiction out here on this hill
with this completely medically
uninformed and unscientific take that's
just i guess honestly just for attention
uh just for attention so
i just want attention what is it that
you want when you talk about me the
title of this video is libertarians
react to three wildest matt walsh trad
con takes parentheses matt wall show
so they put a name in there in their
title twice and i'm the one begging for
attention
but this is the kind of free thinking we
get from libertarians if you have an
opinion that ventures outside of the
mainstream it must be just deploy for
attention these two literally cannot
imagine how or why any human being could
or would ever formulate an independent
thought otherwise they're dumbfounded by
the very idea of ideas
their dumbfoundness is especially
embarrassing in this case because
anxiety and despair are huge topics deep
in important topics and topics that
people have been discussing and debating
for thousands of years
as far as these two are concerned though
the debate is over i guess the
pharmaceutical industry has settled the
debate
we are all now ethically bound to agree
with big pharma or elsewhere harmful
malignant trolls just out for attention
now brad smugly assures us that uh i'm
factually wrong depression is a chemical
imbalance and balancement he says
well the chemical imbalancement theory
of depression was cutting edge about 75
years ago
in this century brad it's roundly
understood by nearly every credible
scientist and researcher to be a
misnomer the drug companies still talk
about chemical imbalancements dumb
libertarians on youtube still talk about
it but the people who understand the
issue
and who want others to understand it
have long since moved on from it there
is in fact no evidence of any simple
measurable imbalance that easily
explains depression you cannot diagnose
depression with a brain scan absolutely
you cannot
and they don't by the way
if you could diagnose it that way that's
how they diagnose it but they don't
you might want to read some literature
on the topic that was written sometime
after world war ii brad just just a tip
okay one more clip let's watch
anxiety and depression can be normal
human experiences if you were
experiencing situational anxiety or
depression and that can be a small blip
that you have to work through say you
know and that that is not a medical
condition right you're not having an
imbalance you're having a rational
reaction to an event somebody dies in
your life you're sad you fall into
depression that is situational
depression and while you can still get
help for that and should especially
things like therapy i would not say
that's a medical condition right same
thing with anxiety like if you're having
anxiety because you're really stressed
and you have a deadline you don't make
it like it's normal to have anxiety
there but then there are actual medical
conditions which are things like
generalized anxiety disorders depressive
disorders and there's many kind of mini
orders underneath those that you can
look up in the dsm but basically they
are things like you and i have i have a
generalized anxiety disorder and what
that means is that i have anxiety
responses that are not normal given the
situation the circumstances
you're not just feeling anxious i'm not
just feeling anxious i'm not responding
to a rational event i am making things
up in my head and overreacting to them
and fixating on them oftentimes to a
point where if i had not received
medical treatment throughout my life i
might fall into things like addiction i
might fall into other harmful behaviors
to escape it i might overreact to
situations in ways that could be harmful
and often these things can lead to
suicide and so to say that these are not
medical conditions it's extremely
harmful it's not based on anything at
all i almost think it's like something
that could make you liable if i mean
your audience is listening to some of
this like didn't work like i would feel
definitely borderline
so the libertarians have actually just
said that i should be legally liable for
my unpopular views on mental illness
these are our free speech champions
folks what's more i should be legally
liable if i convince people not to
purchase products from the
pharmaceutical industry
i mean you'd almost be tempted to think
that these two are being paid by pfizer
but then you realize that pfizer could
afford much more persuasive spokesman
she draws a line between depression or
anxiety felt due to a life event like a
death in the family and pervasive
anxiety felt day to day and often for
seemingly irrational reasons she says
that the latter is in the dsm and the
other isn't but again she's wrong in
fact grief disorder that his grief felt
after the death of a loved one is now
officially in the dsm as a mental
illness i guess that means the free
thinking libertarians have to
uncritically accept it as a legitimate
medical issue i however
retain the right to be skeptical as for
the pervasive and irrational anxiety she
describes that is also very normal
anxiety is one of the defining elements
of the human condition this is why
philosophers have puzzled over it from
millennia it's rooted deep in all of our
psyches there is not one person alive on
earth who is ever totally free of
anxiety anxiety at its basis level is
fear or dread in the face of the unknown
kierkegaard said that anxiety is the
dizziness of freedom now he saw it most
thinkers in history have seen it as an
elemental fact of human psychology only
in modern times have we
compartmentalized
and medicalized it
i'm skeptical of that
i'm skeptical of many popular ideas i
confess this is just one of them another
one is libertarianism though unfairness
i shouldn't blame libertarian
libertarianism for the fact that these
two are such mediocre and unimpressive
representatives of it
and so ultimately they specifically if
not libertarianism as a whole
are the ones who are canceled and we'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire